hello to all like hidoka
around the world wherever you may be
at this moment in time uh we're living
through a pandemic in 2021
and in japan seems like you know is a
japanese martial art
it's the olympic games sad for all the
spectators that cannot go there sad for
the country
not having people from around the world
visit
but the athletes have been training for
this for
years and years if not all their life
we will watch on television
the games those who are interested in
sports
and admire those people that we admire
them getting up at
four or five o'clock every single
morning
training perhaps six to eight hours a
day
and this is their one opportunity to
to be tested to see if they're the
world's best
and this cycle goes on
and in our own small way even though
we may not be the athletes that gap at
four five in the morning
but in our small way we dedicated to
sports or an art that we've chosen
or several arts
i'd like to talk today about
what i'm going to offer the dedicated
aikidoka
in the world who who do want to polish
their art
polish their self polish their internal
spirit
and to understand more about co q and
key
and for this in a few weeks time i'm
going to
be starting
a series of pros and cons about the
techniques
that we all know doesn't matter what
style
please forget styles but you all do
the techniques that i should be
performing
if you a lot of people do have my book
if you don't have my book
you can get this book on amazon i will
send it personally anywhere in the world
i'll be starting that page 101 on taina
there's 70 pages of technical points
so you'll need to be able to refer to
the book as well as
listen to my voice on film
the picture here of me inside of scentsy
perhaps you can't see it
these pictures were taken in switzerland
on a seminar he was
palo colony scentsy wanted to take some
nice clear shots of the mountains in the
background
and i've put a small caption under it
because
it was quite nice that scentsy
being a great master as well as a
wonderful human being he called me over
and before it like a flash i was on his
back
the picture was taken he placed me down
and said
you're not as heavy as i thought tony
now i don't know about kilos but
i weigh around about
17 stone i vary from 16 to
17 stone that's that's a lot of weight
compared to psychosensi i was quite a
giant of a man
and yet to him because the angles of the
technique were perfect
i weighed nothing so as i say you can
pick this up
on amazon and we can go through it
together
if you're interested
now what i'm going to do today is i'm
just going to give you a snippet of what
will be offered to you
for the what i call the serious martial
artist
who wants to be the best they can you
don't have to be an olympian
it'd be nice but uh
it's difficult to reach those heights
but you can be the best
that you can in your own dojo and in
your own mind
and this is where i genuinely would like
to help you
the link below takes you to my patreon
site
where if you become a contributor you
can
access these films and many many others
this is where i teach my in-depth
students
my nearly 50 years of knowledge
that i do not give freely i'll be honest
with you
coquidoza now if you watch
the great masters and the current
masters
of today you will see them
make this movement
your partner grips both wrists you turn
your hands over
and you make this movement
now there's a fault in most
of the people doing this i don't want to
care what level they are they can be an
eighth down
but there's an error that they're making
that cytosensae used to display
but he never talked about it he just
used to say
use coke you
so i'm going to go in the pros and cons
and talk about the detail
of the pros and cons now the con is if
you turn
from the wrists and you really with your
mind
push out power into your hand blade the
tegantana
you can get quite stiff and tense under
here
all the way up to your throat so
really you're blocking cokie you're
blocking
key because you're
you know you're like this you're as good
as you can
push your hands this is not the
releasing of coke
coke you is when the feeling
is puffing up your body
so puffing up means that it's like air
being blown into your body
that way you don't feel tension
in your neck your arms
your mind's not pushing pushing pushing
now for beginners yes you do have to do
this and
push and push and push and push and push
and push
and push and push and push but the more
advanced
expression
they're holding on this expression
and this expression extends away from
you
and it extends like this watch my hands
please
extends away from you
notice that my hands especially
this one i'm going this way for the
camera
it would be the same on both sides but
this hand
now the pros are
this is the level this is the level it
stays at
the cons the pros and cons
is you'll see this done
they cut down this hand so my right hand
is
cutting down their site and the teachers
will say use your
tegantana that cut down the person
like cutting with the sword this is
totally incorrect
totally incorrect it will stop your coke
you from flowing
your coke you must go outwards
what happens then is your cochlea is so
powerful
that it unbalances okay
and when they get to a certain point
here
they start to fall naturally they fall
down
this hand doesn't allow them to come up
to fight against it because your coke
you is powerful
and going outwards
this hand then follows them down
so this hand is like on top of their
wrist
following them down so they won't
come up even if they struggle because
your coach you is powerful
but it's not a cutting down
this is an action a mental action
this is an aggressive action you
become the attacker not the attacked
so if you want to find this word
coke you
once you do this this all-embracing
feeling of joy
that you're experiencing
is key the key
of life is flowing from you the coke you
is the power behind this to drive
the technique so they can't push back
if they you know once you're once you do
this movement
this movement there's several different
cochlea doses standing
coca-naggy it's the same
hey but it's not
you'll notice um some teachers do this
coconutty the hands stay here
you don't see them doing this with this
hand when standing
so you shouldn't do it in kneeling
by holding your wrist firmly or lightly
it doesn't matter
you tie together whether they're firm
feel lightly you extend outwards away
from you now your body stays here it
doesn't lean
like this i'm sitting today on a
meditation storm that i have made for me
to show you that i'm not
coming up off the store
i'm staying on the store and if you
rinse
says that you would stay there you can
come up yes
but if you do come up
you come up directly and then you expand
you don't move forward
or as you're not expanding through your
arms you see
you see for a moment i'm stationary my
arm's not doing anything
my arms hands become stationary
the feeling is expand
expand expand
you unbalance them at this point they
fall down
you follow them down and then you move
in with your
left leg in this case and pin them to
the ground
you all know this or should all know
this coca dozer
just means sitting extension coke you
dozer dozer co-queue
this word code here it's not really used
people are doing this expression
but they cut down this is the fault
this is the pros are
extend
the cones
cutting them down it makes a very small
circle
yes you are on top of them quickly
but it's not coke you it's
entrapment okay
thank you for listening i hope that
you'll
join me on my patreon site this is a
sample of what you'll be getting on
each and every technique through the 70
pages 71 to be precise
and this is a snippet to show you
how so many teachers around the world
are teaching aikido but they're missing
some vital points
and the vital point is the polish that
makes
the athlete you know anybody can run
anybody in condition can run
sadly those who have disabilities that
cannot
hopefully find other ways of exercising
their mind and body
but those who of us who can run we can
all run
but professional will run smoother
faster
and all we can do is watch and admire
i'd like you to be watched and admired
by your students by fellow practitioners
and if you're a teacher i'd like you at
whatever age you are
we can still learn we can still polish
i still get so much joy from just this
movement you don't need a partner to
enjoy it
the tingling and the energy between my
hands and my
whole being is alive
this is coke this is key
thank you for your time